Well, let's talk about breast cancer specific, are there specific genes that you have seen that
are involved typically in the development of breast cancer other than, you know, the
brackaging, which I'd like to ask you about also, because we say bracka and everybody freaks out,
but they don't realize it's a tumor suppressor gene. It's a good gene, you know, and why does it,
why does it mutate? It doesn't, you know, it's not always genetic. So,
well, let's address that, breast cancer specifically.
So, breast cancer specifically, there are certain genes that you want to look for for breast cancer.
Certainly, the two, the, the bracka genes are just one, those are tumor suppressor genes,
not it just in breast cancer, but any hormonally driven cancers. And what people struggle with with
the bracka genes is that typically if they go through their oncologists, they're only going to check
two, three, four, five of the main bracka genes where there's dozens and dozens of bracka genes.
Wow. And it, so, and most people will have multiple defects on their bracka genes,
that that's just can be very normal. So, you have to be careful to, to call the person when you go
over their genes, because the person can be stuck in thinking that if I have a defect, I'm going to
get a disease. That's not true. So, but you definitely look at the bracka genes with any type of
hormonally driven cancer. And then you don't have to be looking at detoxification pathway genes.
And maybe even more important than the tumor suppressor genes, it's that detoxification pathway
genes, and not just breast cancer, but most cancers. Because it is,
something had to get inside the cell to cause that rapid replication in the first place.
It would be a virus. Well, yes, it could be that it's really not going to be affected by the
tumor or the detoxification pathway genes, but more often than not, it's some sort of toxic chemical
that we're exposed to, heads the, the rise in cancers across the, the world in the last 50 years,
because the rise in chemical use, and how that correlates. So, it's the, it's, it's the,
slowly of our detox pathways because of defects that is probably our biggest genetic cause of cancer,
though it's indirect.